[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente
llegó el día en chile tras el estallido
social de 2019 y aplazamientos por la
pandemia del cob y 19 los chilenos
deciden en un histórico plebiscito sobre
un cambio a la constitución que data de
la dictadura de augusto pinochet tras un
lento recuento el tribunal electoral de
bolivia confirmó la victoria del
heredero político de evo morales como
presidente el movimiento al socialismo
de la mano de luis arce vuelve al poder
y entramos en la última semana previa a
las elecciones presidenciales en eeuu y
en nuestro segmento especial camino a la
casa blanca revisamos cómo funciona el
colegio electoral el que elige al
mandatario de los próximos cuatro años y
vamos de inmediato a chile para nuestra
historia principal los ciudadanos
deciden el futuro de la constitución una
cita electoral pactada para abril tras
el estallido social de 2019 pero que fue
pospuesta debido a la pandemia de kobe
19 el reclamo inició por un aumento de
precio del pasaje de transporte público
pero derivó en un clamor por cambios de
fondo en las políticas gubernamentales
que han profundizado la desigualdad las
campañas para cambiar la carta magna que
data de 1980 cuando el poder lo tenía
augusto pinochet estuvieron marcadas por
las medidas contra la pandemia
nuestra corresponsal patricia luna
acompañó los últimos actos en la
búsqueda del voto por el apruebo y el
rechazo
[Música]
el mayor ruido posible a favor del
apruebo el tren de la prueba y la
caravana de motoristas parten su
recorrida santiago en su campaña para
sumar más adeptos queremos hacer un
llamado a toda la gente de la región
metropolitana y el resto de la región
del país que voten a prueba o convención
constitucional y nos ayuden a derrocar
una constitución pinochetista llena de
sangre que ha llenado de desigualdad
todo este país los últimos 40 años los
votantes del rechazo también se hacen
presentes javier a escena de una
plataforma de jóvenes llamada no gracias
que prefieren optar por reformar la
actual constitución de 1980 esta idea de
una nueva constitución nos estaban
vendiendo la pomada que en chile
significa un poco
no están vendiendo gato por liebre que
eso significa en definitiva de que nos
están prometiendo una cosa que en
definitiva no va a ser tal
javiera es una de las jóvenes que
aparece en la famosa franja electoral
que se repite dos veces en la televisión
durante los 28 días previos a la
elección y que juega un rol importante
en los indecisos el apruebo es
mayoritario las encuestas y esto es lo
que nos cuenta la calle prueba
en el cual considero yo que debe haber
un cambio fundamental de raíces en el
sistema que no está gobernando
actualmente apruebo obviamente voy a
votar por el aprueba para prueba voy a
votar rechazo porque porque creo que no
es una propuesta clara creo que
realmente el cambio de constitución fue
impulsado por grupos violentistas y creo
que porque es tirarse a la piscina sin
que haya agua adentro la nueva
constitución fue uno de los mayores
reclamos del estallido del 18 de octubre
del año pasado en el país
por eso la otra campaña se realiza en
los muros de las calles donde la prueba
también es mayoritario el domingo
sabremos si los chilenos deciden contar
por primera vez en sus más de dos siglos
de historia con una constitución elegida
por el pueblo
vamos a bolivia que también tras un
convulso año acudió a las urnas para
elegir a su presidente
recordemos lo que sucedió las elecciones
que se celebraron el 20 de octubre de
2019 fueron anuladas luego de que la
oposición y observadores internacionales
como la organización de estados
américanos denunciarán fraude e
irregularidades a favor del entonces
presidente evo morales quien si bien
lideraba la votación supuestamente no
tenía la diferencia necesaria para
evitar una segunda vuelta
cientos de personas salieron a las
calles a protestar y tras perder el
apoyo del ejército morales quien estaba
en el poder desde 2006 renunció y viajó
a méxico y posteriormente se exilió en
argentina
tras una serie de renuncias de los
sucesores en el cargo que establece la
constitución y que eran cercanos a
morales
jeanine áñez asumió la presidencia
y tras un lento recuento de votos de
esta semana el tribunal constitucional
confirmó que el heredero político de evo
morales
luís arce quien fue su ministro de
economía y a quien se le atribuyen sus
logros económicos fue elegido presidente
lo que significa el regreso del
movimiento al socialismo al poder veamos
quién es el presidente electo en el
perfil preparado por nuestra
corresponsal
mery vaca a la derecha y el mundo de las
transnacionales el litio es y será de
los mismos
el exministro de economía luis arce
elegido por evo morales como candidato
presidencial del movimiento al
socialismo más ofrece la defensa de la
nacionalización y recuperar el
crecimiento que tenía el país antes de
la salida del ex presidente y que en su
criterio ocurrió por un golpe de estado
si la felicidad se trunca en un golpe de
estado
ar se condujo la economía durante 12
años la mayoría en un periodo de bonanza
logró superar un cáncer de riñón y ahora
busca el apoyo de los sectores populares
podemos tener buen gobierno de evo
morales tampoco vamos a decir que no
bien a esto no se conocía antes él
bolivia pues pero como ha manejado un
presidente indígena entonces hemos sido
conocido bolivia los críticos afirman
que el crecimiento fue un espejismo y
que no es atribuible a morales o arte
sino a situaciones excepcionales
comparables con ganarse la lotería dos
veces las de la lotería de las materias
primas con los precios subieron
significativamente el gas minerales y la
soya que nos permitió tener 60 mil
millones de los adicionales ellos como
medio plan marshall a precios de hoy y
la segunda lotería fue que morales
recibió un país sin deuda externa
prácticamente luego de ganar las
elecciones con el 55% de los votos
luízar se enfrenta importantes desafíos
cómo sacar al país de la profunda crisis
económica en la que se encuentra luego
de la pandemia y además reconciliar a
los bolivianos que el último año
estuvieron muy confrontados
[Música]
bienvenidos a nuestro segmento especial
camino a la casa blanca en la recta
final para las elecciones esto es lo que
usted necesita saber y empecemos por la
imagen de la semana
donald trump y yo white en debatieron
por fin en el último cara a cara en
nashville después de la cancelación del
segundo debate por el diagnóstico
positivo por kobe 19 del presidente y de
que un primero en el que más que un
intercambio de ideas hubo un intercambio
de insultos e interrupciones a pesar de
que las acusaciones se mantuvieron este
encuentro fue más civilizado como se
esperaba el ex vicepresidente demócrata
arremetió contra la gestión del
coronavirus por parte de trump
responsabilizándolo de las más de
220.000 muertes registradas en eeuu
200.000 estadounidenses muertos si se
quedan con algo de esta noche escuchen
esto es cualquiera que sea responsable
por no haber tomado el control por decir
no acepto la responsabilidad
cualquiera que sea responsable por
tantas muertes no debería seguir siendo
presidente de eeuu de américa
estamos aprendiendo a vivir con él no
tenemos opción no podemos encerrarnos en
un sótano como hace joe él tiene la
capacidad de quedarse
cerrado no sé obviamente él ha hecho
mucho dinero en alguna parte le gusta
vivir en su sótano pero la gente no
puede hacer eso
[Música]
vamos a washington para hablar con
nuestra corresponsal diana castaña y
ahora vimos en este debate a un trump un
poco más moderado este lo ayuda o lo
perjudica
bueno básicamente esta era la última
oportunidad que tenía el presidente de
donaldson para tratar de disminuir el
sin margen esa ventaja que le lleva yo
bailé con un porcentaje de 7 a 10 puntos
dependiendo las encuestas a nivel
nacional y definitivamente me ayuda a
tener digamos un lenguaje un poco más
moderado en este último debate aunque
las encuestas al día de hoy muestran o
dan como ganador del debate al joe biden
hay que ver y esto se podrá conocer
digamos en las siguientes semanas cuando
se den nuevos conteos de favorabilidad
si el presidente realmente logró
convencer a algunos de sus seguidores o
algunos de los votantes indecisos de
sumarse a las filas del partido
republicano para las próximas elecciones
y si como dices vaivén tiene la
delantera en las 50 encuestas de
intención de voto y teniendo en cuenta
que hay una cifra récord de voto
anticipado como ayuda entonces este
debate a bailén por su parte
bueno está muy claro hay más de 46
millones de personas que ya han votado
en los eeuu este es un récord en
comparación a las elecciones anteriores
y digamos que la mayoría de personas que
han votado anticipadamente pues ya han
tomado su decisión y muchos en esta
semana y en la semana que queda de estos
votantes indecisos podrían también tomar
su decisión y esto es lo que digamos
busca bailén y llevar a cabo digamos una
campaña más agresiva para convencer a
estos votantes también a muchos votantes
jóvenes que aún no les convence ninguno
de los dos candidatos y sobre todo
porque se estima que cerca de un 15% de
personas que lleguen a las urnas el día
de las elecciones no sabrán por quién
votar hasta que lleguen frente a la
balota y tomen la decisión así que
todavía queda tiempo y estará una
oportunidad para bailén de terminar de
mostrar su plataforma y digamos
básicamente mostrar por qué debería ser
elegido como presidente de los eeuu
gracias en washington a diana castañeda
por el análisis del último debate de
cara a las elecciones del 3
noviembre es uno de los sistemas
electorales más complicados incluso
muchos estadounidenses no entienden cómo
funciona en 5 elecciones presidenciales
incluida la más reciente en 2016
el ganador llegó a la oficina oval
gracias al colegio electoral pero perdió
el voto popular
aquí les explicamos cómo funciona este
organismo
los votantes estadounidenses no eligen
directamente a su presidente son en
cambio los representantes llamados
electores quienes tienen la última
palabra sobre quién llega a la casa
blanca en total hay 538 de ellos en el
colegio electoral el número en cada
estado varía según su población
california el estado con más cantidad de
habitantes se tiene 55 alaska en cambio
tiene sólo 3 el candidato que obtiene la
mayoría de votos gana todos los
electores excepto en dos estados main y
nebraska que operan con un sistema
proporcional se necesitan 270 de los 538
votos para ganar la presidencia es un
sistema que a veces ha resultado
controvertido porque un candidato no
necesita necesariamente la mayoría del
voto popular para asegurar una mayoría
de electores
ese fue el caso en 2016 cuando donald
trump perdió el voto popular pero venció
a hillary clinton por la casa blanca
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí y américa recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas
cuídense mucho del coronavirus y sigan
viendo france24
[Música]
hoy vincula morón